carl jung once said until we make the
unconscious conscious it will direct our
life and we will call it fate i want you
to ask yourselves for a moment how
conscious are you of your motivations
and of your drives how conscious are you
of the emotions that impact your
decisions are you aware of them or do
you have a tendency to suppress them
this year and a half of the GSB I've
learned that as a leader I have to be
able to recognize my emotions for the
potential they have to lead me to make
better decisions and to forge stronger
connections growing up my parents made a
big effort to teach my brother and me
important values I recall two of them
today the importance of being genuinely
caring and the importance of being
strong and resilient but very early on I
started to suppress emotions that
contradicted this values I started to
suppress for example fear because it
contradicted being strong and resilient
and this tendency to suppress emotions
has led me to wrong and sometimes
catastrophic decisions and I want to
share a couple with you thick not hung a
Vietnamese Buddhist leader also said
something that resonates a lot with this
value of being genuinely caring he said
the most important gift you can offer
anyone is your attention and yet I was
finding challenging for me to offer my
full attention to my friends and this
became evident last quarter when I took
touchy-feely during this three hour long
sessions I was finding it difficult to
connect with the problem my friends were
sharing I was finding myself being
so absent and distracted but my friends
in this class helped me recognize an
emotion that I was feeling all along for
some of the problems they were sharing
and this motion was contempt I was
feeling it and I was unconsciously
suppressing it because it contradicted
this value in this image image I had
about myself and I have learned from my
parents being genuinely caring but just
being able to recognize it completely
changed my experience in touchy-feely I
was no longer reactive to it but I was
being conscious of it and being able to
regulate my reactions when I felt it and
I found myself being able to pay
increased attention to my friends and I
found myself being able to build
stronger connections by being a better
listener well being a better lizard not
only helped me there it has also helped
me in the most important relationships
of my life for example with my wife was
here today with with us you can ask her
how being a better listener has been
proved a relay a relationship very much
but it's hard to tolerate and accept our
negative emotions by suppressing them we
create the fiction that we are under
control but this is not true when we
suppress them we act reactively and this
is not being in control let me share a
second episode in which suppressing an
emotion led me to make costly decisions
before coming here I was supervising
various projects at a recycling company
I had started with my brothers 10 years
before one of these projects was in a
new field for us in which we had no
previous experience and our partner on
this project started having delays
however at the moment I reasoned that I
shouldn't pay increased attention to
this project given the other important
things I have to attend to but the truth
is that wasn't this logical relation
reason that drove this decision it was
another emotion I was suppressing it was
fear I was afraid of looking deeper into
things and finding out that perhaps I
didn't have the solution the perfect
solution to this problem I was afraid of
looking deeper into things and finding
out that our partner could not deliver
which is what finally happened
but things should not have gotten to
this extreme I should have acted earlier
I should have made decisions but I was
suppressing fear and because I was
suppressing it
I was also denying the importance of
this situation I was suppressing it
because it contradicted and it
challenged my sense of strength and I
recognized this fear I'm sure I would
have acted sooner I would have acted
differently and things would not have
turned out this way but here is an
important thing at the moment when I
suppress this fear I was able to come up
with all sorts of logical reasons to
back up my decision to substantiate what
why my decision to give my attention
span unchanged was the correct one you
see we're very good at justifying our
decisions and at rationalizing
everything we do and and rationalizing
our choices as the correct and logical
ones but when we exclude our emotions
from our decision making process we deny
ourselves from the important information
they convey about us and about the
circumstances we face but fortunately
not everything in my case is bad news I
want to share a final story in which
being able to recognize my emotions led
to more positive outcomes last quarter I
also took the negotiations class with
Margaret Neel highly recommended class
but the most important learning was not
the theoretical component of the class
it was again about myself during
negotiations I had always an eagerness
to reach a rapid agreement and
in reading wanting to reach that rapid
agreement I always made fast concessions
to my counterpart and I saw myself as an
effective negotiator because I could
reach an agreement rapidly but the
reason why I was making so fast
concessions to my counterpart was not
because I was being effective but
because I was feeling anxious and
uncomfortable with perhaps the
underlying notion that I negotiation to
take something away from your
counterpart which is not true because
you you also give something to your
counterpart in both parties emerged
better than what they were and I had the
opportunity this past winter break to
test this awareness back home I have a
chance to lead an important negotiation
for my company and I anticipate
additional emotional reactions and
became comfortable with them and was
able to self-regulate and plan
accordingly
and we closed the deal in better on
better terms than we had initially
expected so the first conclusion is that
feeling fear feeling anxiousness feeling
disdain feeling contempt feeling
jealousy doesn't make you a bad leader
nor does it make you a bad person
it is our actions that define us not our
emotions but by suppressing our emotions
we can make wrong and sometimes
catastrophic decisions and take the
wrong paths and the wrong actions so
finally let me share with you ways in
which you can increase your awareness
that have been personally helpful for me
first of all if you are twin here take
advantage of the opportunities you have
the GSB take a look at the courses that
offer you opportunities to increase your
awareness some very helpful ones
personally have been of course touchy
feely high performance leadership path
to power another one across the street
called stress and awareness that teaches
mindfulness meditation which is a tool
that helps you to sit comfortable with
your current emotions second belt
personal and professional relationships
that are conducive to honest feedback
the best way to learn about yourself one
of the best ways to learn about yourself
is by letting others help by enabling
others to do so finally and most
importantly give yourself time to
reflect to take a step back and gain
deeper understanding of your emotions
and of your motivations and in light of
the initial quote to shed consciousness
to your decisions so that you can choose
your fate thank you